hi I'm Andrew Kreisberg I'm co-creator
and executive the flash and I'm Greg
Berlanti we're really excited for season
two it's gonna have some of the things
as special effects we never tent it and
then we have a sort of a new way to
introduce all sorts of incredible
villains so we couldn't be more pumped
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash season two predictions there
are a couple things we know that are
confirmed a couple things that are still
up in the air careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the finale yet I'm
gonna start with the really big stuff
first most notably the timeline based on
what happened in the episode so here we
go
I know a lot of people are wondering
what's happening because now that the
reverse-flash doesn't exist does that
mean that he never originally came back
in time and killed Barry's mother the
only thing we know is that the big gate
way up in the sky you know like the
Gateway to the multiverse is going to
have some lasting effects on the
timeline so what I think is going to
happen is is that the events of this
finale will stick Barry's mother won't
come back but we will see a lot of other
characters that died people that we
haven't seen in a while coming through
that gateway so when we see other
speedsters when we see some big villains
they'll be from the multiverse in
addition to rising from our current
timeline so the paradox you know big
time vortex created by Eddie's death
isn't going to undo a lot of like the
really big plot points Barry's mother
isn't gonna come back in our timeline
but we could see her in multiverse form
you get how that could work for some of
the other characters too
so like will see Harrison wells will see
the reverse flash will see all those
characters again but it won't be the
original versions they'll be from
alternate timelines like I said you know
there's some things that they know that
they want to do some things are still
figuring out Andrew Kreisberg the
executive producer you basically said
that that big vortex in the sky is gonna
make anything possible that's a goldmine
for writers to bend the laws of physics
because you know what do we know about
the time vortex we really don't
understand how it works the people that
make the show are huge Doctor Who huge
you know Hitchhiker's Guide fans so you
know if you've watched those shows you
know not to overthink the logic of time
travel too much because it's more of a
fantasy there's hard science time travel
like primer it's not gonna be like that
that's like the graduate degree of
time-travel movies so let's talk about
the fun stuff predictions starting with
number seven
Scott is now like the new most powerful
member of Team flash after berry when
the multiverse spills in on itself and
in timelines starts to bleed over into
each other you need a character that can
distinguish between them that's what
Cisco's power is Barry's the one that
can use the Speed Force to travel to all
these different places but Cisco is the
one that's probably gonna help and
create the roadmap map to the multiverse
that actually be a really fun moment to
have in the show they'll probably spend
most of the first half of the season
just trying to figure it out so don't
expect like an actual map of the
multiverse any time soon that's where I
think rip hunter will help out onto
number six they will do a death of
firestorm art that is death of Ronnie
Raymond everyone's been asking the
producers you know what's going on with
legends of tomorrow on firestorm if
Ronnie Raymond isn't part of that
equation and he just said you know I'll
say is no comment so it feels like they
will do like an identity crisis Ronnie
Raymond death during the identity crisis
storyline in the comics Ronnie Raymond
was impaled with a magical story it
ruptured his containment field and the
residual energy like spilled over into
Jason Rusch so he became part of the
matrix that's not what they're gonna do
on the TV show like they haven't done
magic yet so Robbie Amell probably isn't
gonna get skewered with a magic sword or
anything like that but but they will
kill him off in a way that allows Jason
Rusch to become part of firestorm that
could be who the J Jackson character is
they could have just recast firestorm
because they had a different actor
playing him earlier this season just
remember if they do kill Ronnie Raymond
off they could always bring him back
like there's no such thing as death in
the multiverse think about what Caitlin
said in this episode the opportunity to
go back and see someone you love she
cares more about Ronnie than she cares
about destroying the timeline so that
could be a source of falling-out between
her and team flash just like pushing her
on the road to kill her frost like if
Ronnie were to die in the mid-season
finale and Caitlin asks Barry to go back
in time and change things so that he
doesn't and he refuses that just feels
like a really easy moment for them to
give those characters that would propel
them into killer frost I know Caitlin
snows metahuman abilities are big
question mark because she looked very
different in the episode when we got
that glimpse of her it was like you know
her entire body had changed
I think Cisco not having any idea that
he had special abilities is a really
good explainer for that but there hasn't
been a trigger for Caitlin
activate those abilities yet watching
the person she loved most in the world
died that would be a good trigger on to
number five the flash versus arrow
crossover this year will be light
hearted and will kind of rope in with
the multiverse time-travel art time
travel is a huge thing in season two of
the flash so naturally they're probably
gonna try and use that for comedy in the
arrow versus flash crossover the flash
finale was pretty dark but I still think
that they're gonna use that you know the
big fun flais row crossover as something
that's supposed to be funny so
regardless of how dark the season gets
into in terms of storylines and where
the characters go emotionally whenever
Oliver and Barry show up in the same
episode it's gonna be a lot of fun and
they'll use the opportunity to drop some
more references to Oliver's child I know
everyone always asks about that the
flash versus arrow crossover is like the
best place for that it's like the most
comic book thing that the show ever does
on to number four so this is a big one
eobard thawne Harrison wells and Eddie
will all be back Tom Cavanagh is
confirmed to be a series regular in
season two meaning that he'll be in most
of the episodes probably as an alternate
version of Harrison wells like a
Harrison wells who was not killed by the
reverse-flash
on that same token though the
reverse-flash will also be back Matt
ledger who's like the original a Barth
on this guy and the Harrison wells
reverse flash when they show up they'll
also be alternate timeline versions of
that character like multiverse versions
the same is true for Eddie just because
one version of him died doesn't mean
there's not infinite other versions of
him that could show up that's also the
backdoor to like an Eddie version of the
reverse-flash I know everyone's kind of
disappointed that he didn't go all
hunter so Lamont didn't didn't become
like a zoom character but one of the
really big surprises of the season is is
that they said they originally didn't
intend on killing Eddie's character he
wasn't supposed to die earlier in the
season about halfway through they
changed their minds it's just a reminder
that no matter how much they planned
each season out big things can change
along the way like they can change their
minds about certain storylines Rick
cause met the actor that plays Eddie
he's not going to be a series regular
though so if he shows up it'll it'll be
very briefly haunts number three until
rip hunter shows up you know around mid
season finale time Barry is gonna keep
derping across time and space team flash
is just gonna keep making all kinds of
crazy mistakes until rip hunter comes
and explains how Time Trial
works he's part of the time masters it's
built into the name of his organization
he is master of time and space he's like
the Doctor Who of the arrow universe so
expect Barry to make a lot of bad
judgment calls and for some of those to
lead to like big falling outs within
team flash and big consequences with the
villains of the season like maybe it is
a mistake to not go back in time and
save Ronnie if he were to die the
consequence of that is that Caitlin snow
might become killer frost on the other
hand remember what Harrison wells said
if you try and change the past to avoid
a big WTF catastrophe time will find a
way to replace it with another
catastrophe that's just as bad if not
worse and everyone's wondering with the
timeline of that legends of tomorrow
trailer is like when they all meet on
the rooftop in Central City I think that
that's gonna happen around the midseason
finale of air on the flash just to
explain like the reason that Oliver is
wearing the arrow costume but Stephen
Amell said that the arrow costume is
done I think the reason they did it that
way is because they needed to shoot
footage for the up fronts but they
weren't sure where they were gonna take
the story in the first half of the
season like they were still figuring it
out so they were like okay well we'll
just put Oliver in his arrow costume and
then when we actually get to that moment
we'll reshoot it so they don't expect
all that footage from the legends of
tomorrow trailer to show up in the first
episode the same thing happens all the
time with like the big Marvel movies
like there's a bunch of footage in the
age of Ultron trailer that never made it
into the final cut of the movie on to
number two we will see a whole bunch
more Green Lantern related Easter eggs
through arrow crossovers and Co City
no promises for Hal Jordan showing up
but Carol Ferris and Ferris air are very
doable things
remember Cisco said that they had a test
pilot that mysteriously disappeared I
think that's how Jordan I think they'll
use that to explain his absence from
both of the shows like why he doesn't
appear because he's disappeared we have
no idea where he is
everyone else tied to his character
though is very doable the types of greet
you know Green Lantern Easter eggs they
drop I think will be specific to each
show arrow in the flash just because you
know air tends to be a little more
practical real-world stuff and the flash
tends to be a little more fantastical so
they're gonna drop bombs about
intergalactic space cops or sentient
planets it's probably gonna happen on
the flash can't find light my number one
prediction we will see a bunch more
speedsters like Wally West Jay Garrick
jesse quick and like a crime scene
version of berry some of these will be
actual actors that they cast for the
show some will be just like Easter Egg
level stuff the only one that we know
it's confirmed that they're gonna
actually do an actor for at some point
is Wally West like they just keep saying
they're gonna bring him on the show we
saw the Jay Garrick helmet that means
they could bring him on as an actor or
it could just stay it like helmet Easter
Egg level I know a lot of people want to
see John Wesley Shipp be like an
alternate timeline version of Jay
Garrick that feels like a long shot like
it's almost too on-the-nose
like there's winking at the audience and
then there's like beating us over the
head with something that's like way too
obvious and contrived so I'm not gonna
hold my breath
on John Wesley Shipp Jay Garrick but I
mean it could happen when Barry was
traveling through time he also saw
himself in prison I think that that
might be as close as we get to evil
version of Barry but I do think they'll
be Easter eggs for an evil Barry Allen a
la Johnny quick crime syndicate because
of the shows really strong commitment to
diversity I do think that the next
logical step after doing Wally West
though would be doing a female speedster
like Jessie quick no promises on them
actually casting an actor for that but
they said we would see multiple other
speedsters meaning two or more new ones
in addition to Barry so here's my big
question for you guys you know if
they're gonna do more speedsters on the
show which ones do you want to see first
and how do you want them to show up all
things are possible with a world eating
time vortex swirling above you but here
actually here are a few things that I
think the show isn't quite ready for but
that it me know in my work up to in
future seasons first is the antimatter
universe that is just like way too
outlandish for where they are right now
first they have to explain multiverse
they have to explain more than one
version of the earth then you can do
antimatter universe if you've been
reading Darkseid war right now that is
like one of the coolest new comic books
that Geoff Johns is writing very big
anti-monitor storyline don't expect him
to show up on the show anytime soon
either he is like the biggest of big
bads he's bigger than Darkseid and the
show isn't ready for new gods Darkseid
stuff yet I feel like New Gods would be
really good for legends of tomorrow in
season two or season three they're
calling that show like the big summer
blockbuster version of the flash and
arrow New Gods is like such a big thing
that it demands that level of spectacle
so I just I feel like it would
better on that show than it would on
arrow there flash just in general you
know I feel like the producers have done
a really good job of delivering on
everything they promised and everything
that we've asked for as fans you know I
mean there is like a logical progression
like they have to do the small stuff
first before they can work up to the
crazy comic-book stuff they will all be
at comic-con so they'll probably showing
off new footage from all the shows like
all the new seasons I'll be doing videos
for all that that'll be like in the
beginning of July so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff if
there's any bonus videos you guys want
before that just leave your requests in
the comments I might do a flash video
explaining all the different versions of
the flash they were actually like a lot
if you go way back in the comics I am
still planning on doing a Q&A for arrow
in the flash this week in legends of
tomorrow
Supergirl stuff so feel free to leave
questions for any of those shows so
while you guys wait for that if you
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for my flash finale video and you can
click here for my agents of shield
season 3 predictions thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow